we saw a year of rioting we saw uh you
know I talked about this earlier on my
other channel 60 Secret Service agents
injured at the White House after
left-wing groups pulled down the
barricades started fires in in a Secret
Service Guard post and and in the church
60 Secret Service officers injured and
they they they get away with it in fact
when Donald Trump was was brought to the
emergency bunker because of this extreme
violence the media mocked him and made
fun of him and now you have January 6
with those hearings today and it's
inverted completely now the officers are
crying on camera
now of course I think what happened on
January 6 when you actually watch the
footage of the violence was horrifying
and wrong and these people should be
held accountable the problem is you have
a large group of people who see what
just happened they see 60 officers can
be hurt the president can be ushered to
the bunker and the media will laugh
but then you get you know a few hours on
one day with another Riot which is also
bad and they're holding Congressional
hearings about it this is going to
shatter regular people when they're
looking at what's going on and they're
going to say
I'm not playing this game anymore and
what I mean by that I think a lot of
people are going to start becoming just
completely non-compliant in the sense
that they have no confidence in the
system if someone says you know if the
government issues a mandate due actually
they're going to be like why should I
care you know it's a free-for-all on
this side and nothing I'm I'm just not
going to engage anymore this is going to
lead people to feel like the system
doesn't work they are insecure and
they're in their person and their
belongings and their family and it's
going to destabilize the country unless
there is Justice and that means by all
means Justice for the people on January
6th so those rioters who were fighting
with cops and attacking them will get
charged for their crimes but it also
means all of the Riders from the past
year have to be charged and held
accountable as well otherwise you have
anarcho tyranny the government will not
enforce the rights that affect the small
guy and the small businesses they'll
even ignore it when they come to the
White House and the president is ushered
downstairs but then when it's their side
they'll enforce everything with an iron
fist that's going to shatter people
you know the um whether you like Trump
or not
um Trump does love America he does
understand entrepreneurship and both
sides of the aisle all those guys are on
the take
you know Mitch McConnell been in office
for 30 years he's worth 35 million
Pelosi's worth how do you get 35 how do
you get on I mean so they're all Trump's
the only one that's not on the take he's
only one I need to get rid of him and
yeah they finally did but the the the
whether you're left or right the the
people that wake up every day and make
our country great they're just trying to
make the right decision for their
families they're they really you know
you know sometimes I get on my friends
both sides and I love them both
sometimes I argue with my friends on my
life because I'm going I think your
ideology override your intelligence you
know because that doesn't make any sense
but it's a it's a healthy dialogue back
and forth the progressive elite at the
top will scorched this Earth they do not
care about humanity and that's the piece
that upsets me is that I I don't think
that the the folks at the elite
Progressive left top have any regard for
the The Working Man and working women
they refer to him as males you know we
just they just you know it's about
another mouth we got to worry about
mouths mouths yeah another mouths we got
to worry about so wow that's that's
that's creepy man wild animals you know
I think though I think they view it as a
as it's utilitarian right their their
whole view is if we have a million
people and we do something that benefits
900 000 and sacrifices 100 who cares
it's for the good of the collective so
they're willing to sacrifice the
individual not protect those rights it's
part of why centralized planning of
governance doesn't function because
they're out of touch they can't identify
with the crew also because it ferments
revolutions if you keep sacrificing
different groups or or ignoring their
needs because your focus is solely on
the greater Collective you end up with
all of these different organizations
around you saying we're tired of being
mistreated
when you focus on the individual when
you guarantee the individual's rights
you have a whole Grassroots Network
moving all the way up from people who
are like I feel like my rights are being
protected so as the progressive left
starts to gain more and more power
starts to dictate what the Democrats do
you start seeing more utilitarianism and
in turn you're going to see more and
more chaos
yeah I mean I think that's why they left
they leave the borders open to Mexico
because those folks are going to come
over and and vote left and they shut the
borders to Cuba because those folks are
going to come over and say you don't
want to have what we just had for 30
years yeah that's right democracy is
pretty unbelievable in those two border
situations we saw in Miami what the
pollsters were saying was safe Democrat
went Republican because the people in
Miami know exactly what these words mean
the people in in South Texas are
actually experiencing the problem of the
illegal immigration but I will I will
issue a a partial clarification or
partial correction
these people don't need to come and vote
left you know there's a lot of people
who say that if you know illegal
immigrants come across the southern
border they will become citizens
immediately vote you know that's why
Democrats want naturalization but
the census doesn't ask you if you're a
citizen
so when a million people come across the
border this year already
they can they they can place these
people in certain areas
then on the census how many people live
here and that will affect the amount of
electoral votes that reads that area
will have I think it was the Heritage
Foundation said that California gets one
extra electoral vote based on their
illegal immigration
even if these people don't vote because
they can't because they're not citizens
it still is more power in the electoral
process for these these groups now if
they do uh it's also more congressional
seats it's not just the presidential
vote
you will get a congressional seat based
on people who are not citizens so yeah
yeah I got to come clean I've never put
together that illegal immigration can
change the electoral vote I've never put
that together it's pretty that's pretty
interesting Tim just casually mentioned
it to me like two two a month ago and
it's been like ringing in my head ever
since well a lot of conservatives don't
seem to realize that either but you do
have the Heritage Foundation which
mentioned you know it's like one so it's
not like the apocalypse but hey that's a
free precedent yeah that's a it's a free
congressional seat so there now I think
I think California lost a seat I'm not
sure I think New York did uh so there
are changes happening but Donald Trump
was trying to get the citizenship
question on the census
for this reason
so that people who are not citizens
would say they're not a citizen and then
you could have better representation for
American citizens Democrats would lose a
a decent amount of power percentage-wise
if that were to happen so of course it
was blocked and thrown out and what does
that mean it means that you could be a
taxpaying American you could be born
here you could follow all the rules you
got student loans you were told to go to
college you're struggling to find work
you end up as a history major working at
Starbucks you pay your taxes but you're
not getting health care you're you're
you you get you get sick and you go to
the hospital they charge you 10 grand
you don't understand why this is
happening unfortunately for many of
these people you have the Pied Piper of
the press of left telling them the real
problem is not that they've opened the
borders or or that they've destroyed
industry the real problem is the
industry itself
so what happens when you have people who
instead of saying hey wait a minute
maybe it's a problem that a million
people this year crossed our border
welcomed right in by Joe Biden I mean
that is absolutely shocking you see
these videos there's a video that went
viral like a week a week ago the border
gate is open people just walk on through
walk right up to a CBP vehicle hop on in
and get taken off
then we learned there was there was a
whistleblower a two whistleblowers I
believe footage was released do you know
the Biden Administration is smuggling
actually human trafficking migrant
children on planes into States like
Tennessee this was one of the most
shocking things I had ever seen I
couldn't believe it when you have and
they're doing it out of military bases
out of I believe military bases the
Biden Administration these are these are
videos that have been published you see
them taking kids putting them on planes
they flew to Tennessee and then just
released them into community centers
Republican politicians they were shocked
why is this happening they are bringing
they're they're giving themselves more
power now look I got tremendous respect
I say this all the time I have a
thousand times more respect for the
illegal immigrants who come to this
country believing that this is their
opportunity for freedom and opportunity
than I do for the progressive left that
come out and say America is evil and
racist and it's a hellscape
it's that's just not true but a system
cannot be maintained when you have a
million people just come in economies
are not infinite bubbles of free
resources economies have Ebbs and flows
they have balances they're Supply and
there's demand so if you have a massive
influx of a million workers or people
looking for work at the same time you
have massive unemployment and labor
shortages
I mean you're you're adding more
problems to the mix and we've yet to
solve them
well you know 1892 Ellis Island that's
how we all you know most are
grandfathers and great-grandfathers got
over here and they had a process you
know and um you know I think we we want
folks to come to America we just want a
process to get them in and get them in
Legally and I think that if we did in
1892 we should be able to do it today I
agree yeah I often say that uh a lot of
people need to realize this too people
are critical of immigration
when the people immigrate here legally
we're getting them we are getting the
best you know these people who are
leaving Nigeria and come here and
they're extremely successful because we
are getting passionate individuals who
are like I'm gonna have that dream
the challenge I suppose is the people
who are jumping the line we don't know
who they are we don't know where they go
I mean Biden is basically just shuffling
them through and dropping them off we
need to be able to make sure people
survive people flourish and that a
rising tide raises all [ __ ] thanks for
checking out this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time